you don't mind I want to jump into a
different film which is Thor you will
not remember this but I was actually on
set 10 years ago when you were making it
and I remember standing next to Tom
Hiddleston in costume
not knowing who he was and seeing
everything and you know Molnar like I
you know losing my mind as a Marvel fan
I'm just curious back then what a lot of
people don't realize is that was when
Marvel was still releasing movies with
Paramount that they had taken out this
big loan and if these movies were not
successful all the characters were going
to revert to the bank so I'm curious gee
what was it like making a movie like
that where literally the studio's like
the studio either exists because of this
movie or it's dead you know these movies
have to work well what I have to take my
hat off to Marvel 4 was that as a
filmmaker you were not made aware of
that in a way that got in in you know to
stopped you being creative but there was
no question that tonally Thor was
critical after the massive success of
the brilliant Iron Man from mr. Favreau
and you know and and a Robert and then
slightly less successful for them in
their terms of that Hulk the Thor became
critical to to being the tone that the
sort of tonal bridge featuring literally
a Rainbow Bridge as well between as a
worthy earthbound and space bound and
fantasy bound parts of the Marvel
Universe so there was a kind of you know
connective matrix that Thor Asgard the
nine realms and everything that it
involved could provide inside that large
Marvel Cinematic Universe that was
really enormous Lee important that
couldn't be done by the brilliant you
know Captain America because it wasn't
the same material this was the one that
said is there a fantastical future so I
tried knew about I felt I felt that it
was as important as that but also I knew
that I'd listened I could only do the
best job that I could do
and I do think that Kevin Feige Lewis
TSP Esposito Victoria Alonso they they
they kept a steady hand you know they
were they played a great poker game and
their God was in the details it was very
very detailed you know and then they and
they trusted me and they collaborated on
the things that I could be useful with
and they were and they were also
critically aware that and I'll never
forget in the moment that we cast those
two boys this sort of it was like a kind
of it was like a kind of meditation or a
sort of incantation it was Craig Kyle
and Kevin Feige and me in a room at
Marvel Studios at Raleigh studios down
in Manhattan Beach and Kevin Feige must
have walked around with this long oval
table a hundred times on that Saturday
morning as I kept sort of saying I think
we should call them are you sure yeah I
think we should call them well who you
gonna call first I said I think we've
gotta call Chris Hemsworth for where is
he he's in Vancouver he's doing cabin in
the woods for Josh Whedon remember josh
says he's terrific I trust just you know
we've you know what about the other guy
good call immediately and then making
those calls and I knew how profoundly
serious that decision was I
Kevin said he said we'll never make a
more important decision in this company
than what's happening in this room
Saturday morning at 10:30 when you pick
up the phone to Chris Hemsworth and then
Tom Hiddleston it's either gonna work or
it's not good luck that's first of all
that's an amazing story that I have not
heard thank you so much for sharing it
and I and I'm I've wondered this entire
time but one of things I really wanted
to bring up with you was casting Chris
because he and Tom because these two men
have become synonymous with the Marvel
Universe and do they still send you
thank-you cards like you know because I
think that's kind of important I tell
you what I said - well done cut to two -
Chris the other week for extraction in
which I in which I thought he was
excellent it was brilliantly done always
round that and of course I keep up with
Tom I've worked with Tom in the theater
so I keep up with a pair
when Chris was here the last time he
used filming's down in the house of the
family no we keep up a lot and they're
there they've become good friends I
think they see me as ol old crusty
professor you know kind of older advisor
occasionally they're both terrific guys
I'm so so fond of them I think they you
know they did they just did a wonderful
a wonderful job and as you were standing
next to them I mean I just didn't know
how much it would it would change their
lives but but he did and I'm glad it did
and it changed mine too if you don't
mind one more thing about that actually
isn't it a critical individual in that
process unquestionably is the head of
casting at Disney and now Fox Randi
Hillier Sarah Hallie Finn also brilliant
casting director part of that process
but but knowing that Chris who'd come in
at the beginning of the process and was
not at his best could and should come
back was Randy Hiller so I think that
both Tom and and Chris Oh Randy a few
cards and Sarah as well over the years -
are you a bit surprised you are at the
beginning of this superhero mega event
that has now taken over the planet the
superhero genre is the most popular
genre on the planet nowadays it's been
just building and building are you a bit
surprised that after 10 years it's
there's no sign of it slowing down
kevin was asked back then when I start
when I joined the Marvel Universe Kevin
was being asked all the time do you
think people to put us will soon get
tired of superhero movies so that
question was there was there back then
and the the the answer I think is no not
if they are good sure
did you ever think were you I am part of
my last question on Thor other things I
wanted to ask you about but did you ever
contemplate doing another Marvel movie
was it or doing another superhero movie
or did you sort of get your fix if you
will with Thor I've always wondered the
way things worked there was a there was
a version of events where if if sort of
sometimes with these stories I like to
plan them as trilogies but it's much
harder in this world for that to work
out because the stakes are so high
you've got to really see how the first
one does when the first one was finished
essentially it had been three years of
my life three fantastic years of like my
life but I was I needed to recharge on
something else so I was too close to the
glass on that one so I would definitely
never say never again because I say it
changed my life had changed my career
and and I'm profoundly grateful for it I
wasn't ready to go straight into another
one but I liked the idea of you know I'd
love to be planning something that was a
three-party you know in in movie terms
and that hasn't come along yet but maybe
it will